Black holes are structures in
the fabric of space and time
itself, and they're amongst
the most extraordinary objects
that we know that
exists in the universe.
Despite the
mathematical complexity
in describing black
holes, and the myriad ways
in which black holes can
form in the universe,
we also know that they possess a
very striking simplicity, which
is one of the things I
wanted to try and describe
to you tonight.
The modern conception of
black holes began in 2000--
sorry, 1915-- and
it took many years
before the properties of black
holes were properly understood,
and longer again until
we have found evidence
that black holes exist.
But we do know
black holes exist,
and in 2015, there was
a dramatic confirmation
of the existence of black holes,
the first direct detection
of black holes by
the measurement
of the gravitational
waves emitted
by a system of two black holes.
This was a system
of two black holes
that were orbiting each other.
They coalesced to form a
single black hole, and then
that cataclysmic
explosion when they
formed that single
black hole, they
emitted a gravitational
radiation.
That gravitational waves
moves through the universe
and was measured by the
LIGO experiment in 2015.
That was the first direct
detection of black holes.
It was the first
direct detection
of a binary system
of black holes.
Before them we weren't
sure that they existed.
And it was also the
first direct detection
of gravitational waves.
So in short, that was a
truly spectacular discovery,
and that's something
I want to tell you
about in tonight's lecture.
In telling the story
of black holes,
we'll start with the beginning
of the story of gravity,
or the modern story of
gravity, which is Isaac Newton.
And citing from
Isaac Newton, we'll
moved to general relativity,
Einstein's theory of gravity,
which is our best
theory of gravity,
and it's the arena where most
of the discussion of black holes
will happen tonight.
But we know that relativity
is not the final story.
It's not the most
fundamental story of gravity.
We know there's a new
chapter, and the new chapter
must include quantum theory.
So there is some way in
which general relativity
must be subsumed into a deeper,
more fundamental structure.
And I want to explain why
black holes, and the properties
of black holes, are the
key theoretical laboratory
for making that
next step forward
in the search for
fundamental physics.
So I want to begin
our journey in 1687,
which is when Isaac
Newton formulated
his theory of gravity.
And along with his
laws and mechanics,
that comprises,
really, the beginning
of modern fundamental physics.
And Newton thought a lot
about how things fall.
So for example, this apple.
Famously, he thought
about how apples fall.
And he realised that everything
falls in a very similar way,
and in fact, in
exactly the same way.
So that apple falls, as
I've just demonstrated,
this ball similarly
falls in the same way.
And if I take this ball and
impart a small transverse
motion to it, it's still
falling to the Earth
in the same way the apple was.
But because of the
transverse motion I gave it,
the actual orbit was
slightly different.
And Newton thought
about this a lot,
and from these
simple observations,
he made the breathtaking
leap that the moon is also
falling to the earth in exactly
the same way the apple was
falling to the earth or this
ball was falling to the earth.
And he came up with an
ingenious thought experiment,
which hopefully I
can convince you,
following Newton, of
why that's the case.
So here is a picture
that Newton drew,
and it's a picture of a planet.
I'm not quite sure why it
has all these fissures in it.
But in any case, he has a
planet with a little volcano,
a little mount on the top of it.
And he imagined standing
on top of that hill
and throwing objects.
In fact, he thought of having
a cannon and firing cannon
balls from it.
So starting from the point
V, he fires a cannon.
And if it was thrown
at a small velocity,
the cannonball would fall to the
earth and end up at the point
D. If you threw it a little
further, it would end up--
sorry, a little faster--
it would end up at the
point E. But in both cases,
just like the ball I
demonstrated a few moments ago,
it's falling to the
earth all the time.
Faster still, it would go
up to point F, and then G.
And if you took, at the
surface of the earth,
and I took that ball, and I was
able to throw that ball at 7.9
kilometres a second, which,
admittedly, I couldn't throw.
But if it could
be thrown, then it
would keep falling to
the earth the whole time,
but it would never
actually touch the earth.
It would come back and make the
orbit, which was the final line
that Newton drew.
So Newton understood
that all of these orbits,
these closed motion of
particles, like the moon,
are actually objects
that are falling.
So from simple thought
experiments of apples,
he made this leap to the
cosmos, and it was a brilliant,
but simple, insight.
But Newton didn't stop there.
He made this
mathematically precise.
And in Newton's
theory of gravity,
he said that all
objects, all masses,
feel a gravitational force.
There's a gravitational
force between the apple
and the earth.
And we perceive that, as
the motion of the apple
falling towards
the earth, there's
also a gravitational force
between the earth and the moon.
And we perceive that, because
of the transverse motion,
that the moon stays
in a stable orbit.
Newton's theory is
magnificent, and it held sway
for over 200 years.
This was our deepest, most
fundamental understanding
of gravity.
It predicted the motion
of all of the planets
in the solar system,
and it actually
predicted the existence of a
new planet, the planet Neptune.
So by studying the
motion of Uranus,
and it's using the
mathematics of his theory,
people realised that
it almost worked,
that there were some
small deviations.
And those deviations
would be accounted
for in Newton's
theory if there was
another planet in
a further orbit,
just outside the
orbit of Neptune.
And the theory was precise
enough that you could predict.
Well, astronomers predicted
exactly where that planet
should be, and it was found.
So Newton's theory
was quite spectacular.
But there's something very odd
about Newton's theory as well.
And the odd thing is that the
force, the gravitational force
that Newton invoked, is
instantaneously communicated.
So with this apple,
if I move the apple,
the force between the
earth and the apple
is instantaneously communicated.
It doesn't take a little
split second for it
to be communicated,
it's instantaneous.
And this troubled Newton,
instantaneous action
at a distance.
And I want to put up
this fragment of a letter
that Isaac Newton wrote
to Bentley in 1692.
Bentley was the Master of
Trinity College in Cambridge.
And I was actually
fortunate enough
to see this volume at the
Wren Library, just a couple
of months ago.
And I found it very moving
to see Newton's handwriting,
and I felt a physicality,
a connection,
spanning us across these
centuries, that separating us
in time.
In this letter, somewhere
towards the bottom,
Newton said something
quite extraordinary,
so I've highlighted it here.
It says, "that gravity
should be innate, inherent,
and essential to matter,
so that one body may
act upon another at a
distance through a vacuum
without the mediation
of anything else,
is, to me, so great an
absurdity that I believe
no man who has in philosophical
matters, any competent faculty
of thinking, can
ever fall into it."
So this action of
distance is disturbing him
at this very deep,
fundamental level,
and it's worth registering
this for a moment.
So at the very foundations
of his theory, he's troubled.
But nevertheless, despite his
troubles and those obstacles,
he's been able to
build his theory.
And the theory, as I was just
saying, is truly magnificent.
It's not a hodgepodge theory.
It's a great theory.
And it's a little
template, I think,
for how often progress can
happen in theoretical physics.
One doesn't necessarily
have the big picture
and the complete
picture, and there
can be troubling aspects
in your understanding,
but it's the creative act to be
able to pierce through the void
and come through and create
some new body of knowledge,
even though you have at
the back of your mind
some deep reservations that
this is not the final story
and that things will change.
The next chapter began in 1905.
1905, Einstein came up and
developed his special theory
of relativity.
And one of the aspects of the
special theory of relativity
is that Einstein
discovers it and he said
the universe has a speed limit.
And the speed limit is
300,000 kilometres per second.
That's the speed of light.
At this point,
Newton's theory, which
has just been happily existing
as the most fundamental
understanding of
gravity, suddenly
ran into a contradiction,
or a paradox.
If forces instantaneously
communicated in his theory,
and Einstein says that
nothing goes faster
than speed of light,
something has to give.
In a remarkably
short amount of time,
Einstein himself was
the one who worked out
what the next step was.
In 1915, Einstein developed his
general theory of relativity,
and he swept away completely the
notion that gravity is a force.
There is no force of
gravity in Einstein's theory
of relativity.
Instead, gravity is the
manifestation of the curvature
of space and time, space-time.
So we can draw some
pictures to get
some intuition and understanding
of what this means.
So imagine that space
is a rubber sheet
and you place a heavy object
into the rubber sheet,
like a shot put, it would
curve the rubber sheet,
much like in the
picture of the earth
curving the space in the
picture that you can see.
So the Earth's0 curving
space around it,
and now the moon is
orbiting the earth,
not because of
force pulling on it,
but just like a marble rolling
on that curved rubber sheet.
If there was no friction, that
ball, the moon, the marble,
would just roll around on that
rubber sheet indefinitely.
So the slogan of
general relativity
is that matter curves
space and time,
and curved space-time
informs how matter moves.
It's important to
understand and emphasise
that general relativity doesn't
prove Newton's theory is wrong.
That's not the way
science progresses.
What Einstein did, or
what his theory does,
is subsumes Newton's
theory into a deeper, more
profound structure.
And if you take the domain
in which Newton's theory was
developed, essentially,
the solar system,
then Einstein's theory, as
a very good approximation,
does reduce to Newton's theory.
So Einstein's theory
incorporates Newton's theory.
It extends it.
It makes new predictions.
And one of the most stunning
predictions it makes
is that there
exists black holes.
Two or three weeks
after Einstein
wrote down these field
equations, Karl Schwarzschild,
who was a German
scientist who was
in the Prussian front, a
soldier on the Prussian front,
and a few weeks after Einstein
wrote down these field
equations, he found the
first black hole solution.
A black hole is a
region of space and time
in which, once you go
inside the black hole,
you can never escape.
The boundary of the black hole
is called the event horizon.
So if we imagine
we're in a spaceship
and we cross the event
horizon, going from the outside
to the inside of the black hole,
once past the event horizon,
no matter how you
fire rockets, you're
always going to stay
inside the black hole.
Similarly, if you
shine a light beam--
you shine a torch, or
any other light beam--
from inside the black
hole, it necessarily stays
inside the black
hole and won't ever
emanate past the boundary of the
black hole, the event horizon.
So since light can't come
from inside to the outside,
out black.
They don't emit any light.
One of the ways in which
black holes conform
is in the final stages
of evolution of stars.
And evolution of
star is a battle.
It's a battle, on the one hand,
between the matter of wanting
to collapse in on
itself, and the pressure
caused by the thermonuclear
reactions happening deep
inside the core of the
sun, holding that pressure,
the force of gravity, at bay.
So for most the
evolution of the star,
those two forces, using
that Newtonian language,
the force of gravity
pulling the matter in
and the pressure pushing
it out, are at equilibrium.
But as the nuclear
material is exhausted,
the nuclear fuel is
exhausted inside the star,
if the star is big enough,
it will collapse in on itself
and a supernova will happen.
That will collapse in
and then explode off
and, again, if the
star is big enough,
there will be a core of matter
inside the interior of the star
that will keep
collapsing in on itself
and will form a black hole.
One of the most extraordinary
facts about general relativity
and these black holes is,
despite the complexity
of what I've just said,
how a black hole can form--
after all, the star could be 20
solar masses, 50 solar masses--
you think of the complexity
of the supernova explosion,
how much matter is ejected,
and so on and so forth,
the final black
hole that is created
is specified by two numbers,
its mass and its spin.
All the other information
about the black hole--
sorry, all the other
information about how
the black hole was formed--
is lost, and you just left
with those two numbers.
Actually, to be more
precise, there's
three numbers,
and exactly three.
So now this is a fact.
The third number is the electric
charge, but in practise,
the electric charge in
astrophysical black holes is
going to be extremely
small, or non-existent,
because charge will naturally
neutralise the black hole very
quickly.
But the mathematics of
relativity says it's specified
by three, and in practise,
it will be just the mass
and the spin, which will
determine the properties
of the black hole.
So that's what I
wanted to mention.
That's what I mentioned at
the beginning of the lecture,
that black holes, in general,
extremely are extremely simple.
If black holes are black,
how do we detect them?
Here is, I quickly add,
an artist's impression
of a star in a black hole.
It's a companion
system, a binary system.
And the black hole is spinning.
And you can see that
it's stripped off,
or it is continuing to strip
off, matter from the star.
And as it strips off the
matter, because the black hole
is rotating, that matter gets
swirled around the black hole
and starts to form,
heat up from a plasma.
In fact, that plasma, as it
generates magnetic fields,
it also shoots up these jets
along the axis of the direction
which it's spinning.
This plasma reaches
very high temperatures
and starts to emit X-rays.
And the first indirect
detection of black holes
came from measuring the X-rays
produced by black holes,
as in this picture.
We now know that there's many
black holes in the universe
by these indirect tests.
And in particular, there's
a supermassive black hole
at the centre of our galaxy--
our galaxy, the Milky Way.
It's in the constellation
of Sagittarius,
and it weighs three or
four million times the mass
of our sun.
In fact, most galaxies
in the universe we think
has a similar sized black
hole, or even bigger.
There's another very beautiful
piece of indirect evidence
for the existence of this
black hole in the centre
of our galaxy.
So here is a picture of--
I'm going to run a little video,
and it's a video of the motion
of stars right at the
centre of our galaxy.
It was taken over 14
years, and the red cross
is the place where we think the
supermassive black hole exists,
and there's no light being
emitted from that region.
So the date was taken
from 1992 to 2006,
and let's have a look at it.
So one thing I
should quickly add.
This is not a simulation.
Often, you see simulations,
but this is real data.
This is real observations
of individual stars around
the centre of our galaxy.
And if I just stop
at about here,
you see we have these
nice elliptical orbits
of these stars going
around the central object.
And by studying the detailed
shape of those orbits
and the time taken for the stars
to go around a complete orbit,
we can use the mathematics
of general relativity
to deduce what the
mass of the object
is that they're
orbiting, and that's
three to four million
times the mass of our sun.
And in addition, if I just
take it a little bit forward,
there's two orbits
that get extremely
close to the central object,
but don't hit whatever it is.
So we know the size,
as well as the mass,
and we know of no
other object that
can weigh three or four million
times the mass of the sun
and squeeze into that amount
of space, except a black hole.
So we believe there is a
black hole at the centre
of our galaxy.
So these are the
indirect ways to check
the existence of black holes.
Let me come on to
the direct way.
In 1916, just one year after
Einstein formulated his theory
of general relativity,
he realised that general
relativity predicts that
gravitational waves exists.
As matter moves
through space and time,
it forms gravitational waves.
And the picture you
can have in your mind
is that as you move your hand
through the surface of a pond,
you form ripples on the
surface of the pond.
Similarly, as mass moves
through space and time ,
it forms gravitational waves.
In fact, as we're
moving around, we're
forming gravitational waves.
However, these gravitation
waves of the motion of ourselves
are extremely tiny.
The gravitational waves caused
by the Earth orbiting the sun
are also extremely tiny.
As the Earth orbits
the sun, it's
emitting gravitational
waves in all directions,
and you can calculate what
the total amount of power
is from all those gravity waves.
So imagine you gather
them all together
and say, how powerful is that?
That would be powerful enough
just to light up a light bulb.
So even though these are
existing, the sun and the earth
is only producing these
tiny, tiny little ripples
in space and time.
There's a reason for
why these are so small.
And the reason is that gravity
is an extremely weak force.
So I'm going to use
the Newtonian language
because it's convenient here.
We're not used to thinking
of gravity as being weak.
For example, if we jump,
we fall to the ground
and it feels like
gravity is pulling us
down with a strong force.
But we can do a very
simple experiment
which compares gravity, and
the strength of gravity,
to another force.
And it's a very
simple experiment,
but it's an
important experiment.
It involves a magnet
and a paperclip.
And obviously, just like the
beginning of the lecture,
if we drop the paperclip,
it falls to earth
under the influence of gravity.
But I can compare the
gravitational force
of the whole of the planet
Earth on that paperclip
to the electromagnetic force
on this tiny little magnet.
And we know what will happen.
It holds it up.
And it's a simple observation,
but it's a profound one.
It tells us that gravity
is extremely weak.
It's just that when all the
other forces are not around,
gravity is the only
one left, and it
dictates what's going on.
So gravity is weak.
Gravitational waves
are very small.
If we're going to have
any hope of detecting
gravitational waves, we're
going to have to look
for a cataclysmic explosion.
And a cataclysmic explosion
is the coalescence
of two black holes.
So we imagine we have a
system of two black holes,
perhaps formed like the
picture we had before--
one went supernova,
formed the black hole,
and then the companion star
later also formed a supernova
and turned into a black hole.
And those black
holes were rotating,
spinning on their own
axes, but they're also
rotating around each other.
Because of the simplicity
of black holes,
specified by their
mass and their spin,
we can calculate how much
gravitational waves would
be admitted by the system.
If every black
hole was different
and a highly complicated
individual object,
we wouldn't be able to do this.
But that simplicity
of black holes
allows us to
calculate the gravity
waves that are produced.
And here is a prediction
from general relativity
of the gravity waves
that are produced.
So we're imagining the two
black holes orbiting each other.
Their emitting
gravitational waves.
As they emit the gravitational
waves, they lose energy
and they get closer and
closer to each other,
and they eventually inspiral
and form a single black hole.
So on this graph, on
the vertical axis,
I've got the strength of
the gravitational waves,
and on the horizontal
axis, it's a time scale.
And you'll notice that the
time scale is in roughly tenths
of seconds.
So we're looking at the very
final part of the coalescence
of these black holes.
For millions of years,
they'll be actually rotating
around each other, producing
gravitational waves
at a constant frequency,
like on the left-hand side
of the graph.
As they get closer, in the
final inspiral and coalescence,
the frequency of the
gravitational waves goes up
and the amplitude goes up.
They form a single
black hole, and then
the strength of the
gravitational waves dies away.
In fact, this frequency of
these gravitational waves
being produced in
this process of almost
the same as audio frequency.
So people talk about the
gravitational waves signals
using the analogy of sound.
So the frequency is constant,
and then as they coalesce,
it goes up in
frequency and louder,
and then it suddenly rings down.
So it's called a
chirp and ring down.
So it would be
something like wooop.
That's a sound
version of that graph,
if you don't like
looking at graphs.
The point here is that the
simplicity those black holes
and general relativity allows
us to determine that signal.
So we know, out of prediction
from Einstein's theory
of relativity, of what
gravity waves are produced,
gravitational waves, are
produced by these systems.
How do we measure them?
The technique is
laser interferometry.
And being a theorist,
I love the fact
that I can now play around
with some equipment here,
and hopefully not break it.
What I brought in is a
laser interferometer.
And maybe if we can just have--
yeah, the picture there,
let me just switch this on.
It should just start
warming up in a second.
OK, right.
So what have we got here?
I've got it in a black box.
It's not very dangerous, but
it's a little bit dangerous.
So you can't see
it, but you can see
from above what's happening.
We have the laser here, and
it's emitting a laser beam
straight out the end here.
And this little object
here is a beam splitter.
So half of the light
gets reflected up here
to a mirror, which then
gets reflected back,
and then will go
straight forward.
And the other half will
go through to this mirror
and then come back
to the splitter
and then go off
in this direction.
So there is a coherent
laser light beam that's
split into two beams and then
is sent down in this access.
So let's have a
look what happens.
And if we can have
the lights down.
There are the two
beams I mentioned.
And something interesting
happens if we manipulate them
So they're sitting
on top of each other.
This is the phenomenon
of interference.
Light is a wave, and just
like water waves on a pool--
on the surface of a pond,
or something like that--
interferes, light
wave also interferes.
The point about this set up is
that this interference pattern
is very sensitive.
And if you change the
geometry a little bit,
fire a sound wave, then you see
that the interference pattern
changes.
This is exactly the
principle that's
being used in the
LIGO experiment
to detect gravitational waves.
Taking laser beams,
interfering them,
and then seeing when the
gravitational wave comes in,
that the interference
pattern has moved.
So can I have the
lights back up again?
Thank you.
And can we have the
slides back as well?
Thank you.
So here is a photograph, two
photographs, of two detectors.
One in Hanford in Washington,
the upper left-hand side
of the United States, and
the other one in Livingston
in Louisiana, down
in the lower right.
And the pictures above them are
pictures of the two jet LIGO
detectors.
And you can see that
there's two long arms,
and down each of
those arms, which
are actually four
kilometres long,
a laser beam is being sent.
It's being sent and
there's a big mirror
at the end of one arm.
There's a big mirror at
the end of another arm.
And the light's coming back,
and it's being interfered,
much in the same way we
just demonstrated here,
at that central
detection facility
at the apex of the two arms.
If a gravitational wave
comes through this system,
it tends to squeeze
one of the arms,
makes a little bit shorter,
makes the other arm longer,
or vise versa.
The gravitational waves that
were caused by the two black
holes colliding, that
were observed in 2015,
changed the length
of these arms,
these four kilometre arms, by
1,000th the size of an atomic
nucleus.
This is truly
breathtaking engineering.
All vibrations-- for example,
me hitting the table,
just like a few moments
ago-- would completely
swamp the signal.
All seismic vibrations--
all vibrations
of machinery in the laboratory,
et cetera-- all of that
has to be shielded away by
elaborate and sophisticated
engineering.
And once that's happened, you
have this perfectly stable
system.
If a gravitational wave comes
in, it produces a signal.
And you're waiting for the
movement of 1,000th of the size
of the diameter over
four kilometres.
One of the key aspects
of this experiment
is that there should be two.
The distance between
the two detectors
is about 3,000 kilometres.
So given that
gravitational waves
move at the speed of
light, the time taken--
the gravitational wave will
hit one of the detectors first,
and it will hit the second
one a little bit later.
And a little bit later
is exactly quantifiable.
It's about 10 milliseconds.
So if a gravitational
wave signal has come in,
the two signals,
when you move them
on top of each other
separated by 10 milliseconds,
should be the same.
And in the lower right-hand of
the figure of the image, that
is actually the real data
that was published by the LIGO
experiment, saying we have
detected gravitational waves.
Now, it's true that there's
a lot of noise there,
but the main feature that
I want you to pick up on
is that they are exactly
in phase, especially
towards the latter
part of the event.
They're exactly in phase.
You can see that constant
frequency process,
the increasing amplitude, the
chirp, and then the ring down.
As I said before, this was
the first direct detection
of black holes, the
first direct detection
of gravitational waves, and
the first direct detection
of a binary system
of black holes.
So if you think about
it for a moment,
it's very hard to
know that you have
a binary system of black holes.
A black hole and a star,
you look for X-rays,
and you also see the
light coming from a star.
But if you have just
two black holes,
they might be producing X-rays
from some remnant, accretion
that surrounds them.
But you wouldn't know if
that's one black hole or two
black holes.
So this is the first
direct evidence
that there are binary systems
of black holes in the universe.
I've blown your mind
once, hopefully,
about the engineering feat.
I want to blow your mind again.
By studying that
signal and comparing it
to the theoretical
observations predictions
from general relativity, we
know that the masses of the two
black holes were 36 times the
mass of our sun and 29 times
the mass of our sun.
In fact, before
this experiment, we
didn't know such black
holes of that mass existed.
They coalesced to form a black
hole, which weighs 62 times
the mass of our sun.
So there's one equation in
this talk, and here it is.
36 plus 29 minus
62, and that's 3.
So after they coalesced,
there was three times
the mass of the sun of
matter that was ejected
into gravitational waves.
And the amount of energy
that is, you use the famous E
equals mc squared
equation of Einstein.
And that was released in
a tenth of a second, which
was that final chirp on the
graph that I showed before.
The amount of power that
was produced in that moment
was 3 times 10 to the 49 watts.
Even if you have
facility with numbers--
you're a mathematician
or you're a physicist--
when you get numbers
like this, 10 to the 49,
that's 1 with 49 0's following
it, you lose intuition.
This is a huge number.
So you can try and
think about, what's
a powerful object that you
know about in the universe?
You might begin on earth
with powerful objects,
nuclear reactors, for example.
Forget that.
Let's go to the sun.
Let's think of the
sun for a moment.
All of the power from the sun
reaching us about 90 million
miles away, driving all of
life on Earth, that power,
the total power
emitted by the sun,
is about 10 to the 24
watts, 1 followed by 24 0's.
So this is much, much
more powerful than all
of the power emitted by the sun.
In fact, it's more power
emitted by all of the stars,
not just in our
galaxy, but in all
of the galaxies in the universe.
So when I mentioned
cataclysmic explosion earlier,
this simplicity of space-time,
just the mass and the spin
swirling around each other, that
rearrangement of space and time
into a single black hole
is truly cataclysmic,
and that's despite the
fact that gravity is weak,
in the sense that I was
describing it before.
We also know that the
event happened about 1.3
billion light years away.
That means the
gravitational waves
were emitted about
1.3 billion years ago
and then arrived
at Earth in 2015.
And I find that kind of poetic.
1.3 billion years
ago, Earth had just
evolved from single
celled organisms
to multicellular organisms.
And we wait a little bit longer,
and multicellular organisms
become fish and reptiles.
Dinosaurs come, dinosaurs go.
Mammals come, evolve.
Humans evolve.
Isaac Newton comes.
Einstein comes.
We start building this detector.
And I say we because it is we.
It is humanity who does this.
We build this detector, and
finally, when it's ready to go,
it has its upgrade,
we switch it on.
And actually very soon after
the upgrade, we switched on.
Bang, the signal is
there, coming towards us.
I also want to
emphasise at this point
that gravitational waves,
observations that we've had,
and there's been
three more since then,
there was just one two days ago.
You may have noticed
that in the news--
it's not just verifying
that Einstein was right.
It's not verifying that,
oh, black holes really do
exist, confirming what we knew.
That's all true, but the
really exciting thing
is it's a new type of
astronomy that's being created.
We now have a new window
at looking at the universe.
Not through electric
electromagnetic radiation,
like in the telescopes
we've been using,
but by gravitational waves.
And we're going to learn
more about black holes
and their properties
and their distribution,
and we probably are
going to learn things
that are brand new
that we haven't
thought about before as well.
So gravitational wave
astronomy and observations
over the next 10,
20, 30, 40 years
is going to be an extremely
exciting field in science,
or fundamental science.
OK, so let's leave
the observations
and let's go back to some
theoretical pondering.
Let's return to the
question about what
happens inside a black hole.
So the two figures here
are Stephen Hawking,
of course, and Roger Penrose,
who in the '60s and early '70s
really pioneered and laid the
foundations for understanding
the true properties
of black holes,
and in particular, what happens
deep inside the black hole.
If you cross into the event
horizon, as I've said before,
you are never coming out
past the event horizon.
In fact, if you crossed
a big enough black hole,
you wouldn't even notice
that anything was different.
You would feel exactly the same
as if I stood on this table
and jumped off the
table, so I would
be in freefall for a moment.
That sense of freefall
would be exactly what
you would feel, if the
black hole was big enough,
as you crossed
the event horizon.
As time went on, you
would then find, actually,
you would be squeezed
and stretched.
It's called spaghettification.
You'd be squeezed and
stretched, and eventually, you
would confront what's
inside the black hole,
this space-time singularity.
And this space-time
singularity is inevitable.
And the picture I've drawn
doesn't capture a key feature
of space-time singularities.
And the key feature of
space-time singularities
inside black holes is that
they're singularities in time
and not in space.
If a singularity was
a point in space--
let's imagine it was in
the centre of this room--
you have this strong sense that
you should be able to avoid it.
If you find your
rocket, surely I
could just move away from
the space-time singularity.
Why do I have to hit the
space-time time singularity?
That's true, and that's because
space-time singularities
and black holes are
not of that form.
Space-time singularity
is a singularity in time,
and you should think of a
moment in time in the future
that you can't avoid.
We can't avoid next Tuesday,
and that's exactly--
not rough, exactly--
how you can't
avoid the space-time
singularity in a black hole.
And it's this change of grammar
that's actually important.
A space-time
singularity happens.
You go inside the event horizon
and the space-time singularity
will inevitably happen.
For the biggest black
holes that we know of.
It's of the order of 100 hours.
Inside the black hole in
the centre of our galaxy,
it's about three hours, I think.
Or maybe it's one hour.
It's roughly that.
Interestingly, the longest you
have before the singularity
happens is just to relax.
You just freefall, and that's
the longest you've got.
Any other motion you do, if
you switch on your rockets,
it makes your--
the singularity happens quicker.
I think there's a life
lesson there somewhere,
but I'm not sure what it is.
But it's interesting.
I think it's not
emphasised enough,
that one more level of
that analogy with Tuesday
is firing your rockets
trying to avoid
the space-time singularity would
be exactly analogous to say,
I'm going to hop in
my car and I'm not
sure which direction
you are driving,
but you just try and drive
away from next Tuesday.
It's meaningless.
And similarly,
that's exactly what's
happening inside the black hole.
So what is a
space-time singularity?
So a space-time
singularity is where
the laws of general
relativity break down.
So general relativity
is no longer
valid at the
space-time singularity.
And at first hearing this, that
sounds like a very bad thing.
It sounds like general
relativity is no longer--
it's somehow a flawed theory.
It can't tell us what we need
to know about what would happen
deep inside a black hole.
But, in fact, that's completely
the wrong way of looking at it.
What the space-time
singularities are telling
us is that there's
an opportunity
for deeper insight into the
fundamental laws of physics.
We know that general
relativity is not
the theory of everything.
After all, it
doesn't describe any
of the quantum
forces, which we'll
be discussing in a moment.
So there must be a bigger
theoretical framework,
deeper fundamental physics,
beyond general relativity.
And what the result of Stephen
Hawking and Roger Penrose says
is that black holes
are a great place
to think about where you
should go beyond our existing
knowledge.
Black holes aren't
the only place
that space-time
singularities exist.
They also exist at the very
beginning of the Big Bang.
So if you look at all
the galaxies today,
they're all expanding
away from each other.
If you run the history of the
universe backwards in time,
those galaxies will be getting
closer and closer and closer.
And about 14 billion years
ago, all of those galaxies
would be on top of each other,
and that would be the Big Bang.
And that moment if the
Big Bang, in the context
of Einstein's theory
of general relativity,
is a space-time singularity.
So another place to think
about fundamental physics
beyond general relativity is the
very beginning of the Big Bang,
or the very early
part of the universe.
Up until now, I've just been
just describing gravity,
but I now introduce
another player
into the game, which
is the quantum world.
All of fundamental physics
rests on two pillars.
On the one hand, Einstein's
theory of general relativity,
describing gravity.
And on the other,
the quantum world,
which describes all of
elementary particle physics--
electrons, protons,
neutrons, quarks.
All of the elementary
particles that
are observed in the particle
accelerators, including
the Large Hadron Collider, are
described by the quantum world.
And there's something
called the standard model
of particle physics, which
encapsulates our deepest
understanding of
elementary particles
and their interactions.
Both of these fundamental
theories are extremely accurate
and describe nature with
exquisite precision and beauty,
but they're mathematically
inconsistent.
And that's a paradox
when you first hear it,
but it has a very
simple explanation.
When I've been
describing gravity,
I've literally been forgetting
about the quantum world.
And we can do that because
all of the quantum forces--
for example, the electromagnetic
force is one of those forces--
are neutralised over the scales
that I've been describing.
So the only force
that's important,
using the Newtonian
language of gravity
on the scales of black holes
and galaxies and so on,
is gravity itself.
And we use Einstein's
theory of general relativity
and forget about
the quantum world.
Similarly, when people
do experiments in Geneva
at the Large Hadron
Collider, they
understand and appreciate that
the gravitational interactions
are extremely tiny compared
to the interactions they're
looking at.
Think of the paperclip
and the magnet.
And they, again, pretend that
gravity doesn't exist at all.
They just pretend
it's not there.
So in both domains, we're
approximating what's going on.
The quantum world,
we approximate
by saying there's no gravity.
And in these descriptions
of black holes
and gravitational
waves, and so on,
we approximate by saying the
quantum world doesn't exist.
But nevertheless, we would
like to do better than that.
We would like to put
these both together
into a cohesive,
logical framework.
And the question
remains, then, is
how do we unify these two
great pillars of knowledge?
So in the rest of the talk,
I want to just give you some
flavour why we think black
holes are the key laboratory,
or a key laboratory, for that
next stage of unification
in fundamental physics.
I can just tell you one
thing about quantum theory
to motivate what
I wanted to say.
In quantum theory, the
vacuum, empty space and time,
is actually not as empty
as you might think.
A way of thinking
about it, it's a sea
of virtual particles
and anti-particles
coming into existence out of
nothing, literally nothing,
existing for a little while,
and then annihilating away
to nothing.
So in this picture, I've got--
a red arrow might
represent an electron
coming into being with its
anti-particle, a positron.
They exist for a little,
short amount of time,
and then they annihilate away.
And we call these
particles virtual,
because they're not
directly detected.
However, they can be
indirectly detected,
or their effects can
be indirectly detected.
And they can be measured, and
we know that these are real,
So our conception of what the
vacuum is in quantum theory
is changed from
our naive picture.
Stephen Hawking asked
the great question,
in essence, what happens to
these processes in the presence
of a black hole?
Now, Stephen
Hawking did not have
the theory of quantum gravity.
This is a work in progress.
But he's taking one component
of the quantum theory
and taking a component
of general relativity,
a black hole, and
fusing them together
to obtain some insight.
And by doing a
specific calculation,
he showed that the
following happens.
Away from the black
hole, these processes,
these virtual
processes, continue
much as they were happening as
if there wasn't a black hole.
But near the event
horizon, occasionally
one of these particles
can be stripped off,
one of the virtual particles
it goes inside
the event horizon,
and the singularity
will happen for it.
The other particle can escape
away from the black hole.
And in this process, the
particle that escapes
turns into a real particle.
So the net effect
of this process
is the black hole, with this
virtual processes happening
all over the place, is
such that, effectively,
the black hole is
emitting particles.
And it's not just emitting
particles in any old way.
It's emitting them in
a very precise way.
It's emitting them it as
if it was a hot object
with a temperature.
And this Stephen Hawking's
famous Hawking radiation.
There's more.
The properties of black
holes obey a series
of laws, which have the same
form as the laws governing
thermal systems.
A thermal system is any
system involving heat,
so think of a steam engine.
There's very precise
laws that were developed
in the 19th century to describe
the physics of steam engines,
and any objects involving heat.
And these laws have
a great universality,
that are another
great achievement
in the quest for understanding
fundamental physics.
They explain, for example, if
you pump up a bicycle tyre,
the valve will always get hot.
If you release the valve and
the air comes rushing out,
the valve will get cold.
If it's a hot, sunny day
and you're in your kitchen
and you think you'd like
to be cooled down a bit,
you might be tempted
to open the fridge door
and the cold air comes out.
But these laws
that I'm describing
would say if you do that,
overall, the temperature
the room will increase,
because the heat being produced
at the back of the
fridge will always
be bigger than the
cold air coming out
of the fridge, or the
reduction of temperature.
So these laws, they
basically govern everything
in everyday life with
anything to do with heat.
It's quite remarkable
that black holes
obey these same kinds of laws.
These laws of
thermal systems were
developed in the
mid-19th century,
before atoms were
universally accepted
as fundamental building
blocks of matter.
When the atomic
theory came along,
people realised that it
explained where these thermal
those came from.
The thermal laws have a
microscopic explanation.
So for example, take
a hot cup of tea.
It has heat.
It has a temperature.
But we from the point
of view of atoms, that
can be explained in terms
of the individual motions
of the atoms.
So heat is this disordered
motion of the atoms.
That's what it is, in terms
of this atomistic big picture.
And for example, the
temperature of the tea
is determined by the average
speed of these atoms.
So the atomic picture
provided a deeper, more
profound understanding of
what these thermal laws were.
And that's the status of
black hole thermodynamics,
or thermal physics,
at the moment.
We know that they
obey a series of laws,
but we don't have the
underlying picture
of atoms of space and time
which explains those laws.
So that's one of the big
outstanding question, what
is the microscopic
description in understanding
of these thermal laws?
What happens when the black
hole emits its particles,
more and more particles?
Eventually, it will
reduce to nothing.
And remember, I said
in general relativity,
black holes are very
simple, that no matter how
they were formed, from all
the matter of the collapsing
star, material in the
star, they were then
specified by the mass and the
charge, the mass and the spin.
If the black hole
then evaporates,
producing all this
thermal radiation,
it seems like we have a process
in which information has turned
into pure thermal
radiation, and that
goes against the grain
of quantum theory.
That's a major
outstanding question,
what happens to the black
hole as it fully evaporates?
A variation of that
question is the singularity
inside the black
hole will be revealed
when the black hole evaporates.
So what is the nature of the
singularity, and what is that?
These new atoms of space and
time tell us what that is
and how it's resolved.
This is the cutting
edge of research
into black hole physics today.
So I just wanted to end the talk
with some comments about string
theory.
So string theory is an attempt
to unify quantum theory
with Einstein's theory
of general relativity.
And the fundamental
idea of string theory
is extremely simple.
The idea is this.
If you zoomed in
into the atom, you
would find a halo of electrons
surrounding a nucleus
of protons and neutrons.
If you zoomed into the
protons and neutrons,
you would find quarks.
If you zoomed further
into the quarks,
we don't know what
you would find,
but we think you'll find
something, some deeper
structure.
But don't go to the next step,
go all the way to the end,
and what is the endpoint
of that process?
And the end process,
it's postulated,
is that the fundamental
building blocks
are strings, these one
dimensional filaments of energy
which would have no
further substructure.
And one of the most
appealing things in strings
is that the different
vibrations of the string
would correspond to different
elementary particles.
So the one string, if it's
vibrating, just like a violin
string, one note would
correspond to an electron,
another note would correspond
to a quark, another note
to a photon, a
particle of light,
and also another vibration
would correspond to a graviton,
a quantum particle of gravity.
So we don't know yet if
string theory is correct,
but research in string theory,
or a large branch of research,
is trying to address
these questions
of the thermal
properties of black holes
to have a deeper understanding
of what black holes are,
as well as to get evidence
that string theory is actually
on the right track, and it
is the theory that unifies
quantum theory and gravity.
So in tonight's
lecture, I wanted
to tell you several things.
The first was that black
holes are really cool.
They're structures in the
fabric of space and time itself.
They have this
beautiful simplicity,
and they really are amongst
the most extraordinary objects
that exist in the universe.
Black holes are real.
We've had indirect
evidence that black holes
are real for a long
time, but we now
have this beautiful direct
detection of black holes
that was made by
the LIGO experiments
in 2015, and then
three times since then.
And this section of
gravitational waves
is presaging in a
new era of astronomy.
This is not the end of a story.
Like many developments in
physics, as one story ends,
a new one opens up.
And the new one
that's opening up
is this new era of astronomy
using gravitational waves.
For example, one of the things
that we're going to do--
we, I include humanity
in the we there--
is put satellites up in
space, and they're going to be
separated a million
kilometres apart,
and we're going to be looking
to the gravitational waves that
might change the length, that
million kilometres by 1,000th
of the size of the
diameter of a proton.
It's breathtaking what we
are thinking about doing,
and it's being
planned to be done
in the next 20, 30, 40 years.
So black holes are real,
and finally, black holes
are the way forward.
By thinking about
quantum theory,
we know that there
are thermal objects.
We know there are space-time
singularities, where
we need a quantum
theory of gravity
to tell us what's going on.
And black holes, and thinking
about their properties,
is the arena in which we
think that we can get the most
insight in that next step.
The last point I wanted to
make was a recurring theme
that's gone throughout the
talk is that, often, there's
very long time scales between
developments, both in theory--
development of fundamental
theoretical physics
over the scale of
hundreds of years.
Sometimes it's punctuated
by rapid development,
but often it's over the
scale of 100 years--
and also, experimental
verification.
Predictions come up
with new theories,
but we sometimes have
to wait 10, 20, 30,
again, up to 100 years
before we get evidence
and confirm the predictions.
But that's the nature of the
activity we are undertaking.
And even though the
progress can be slow,
the clearest message
that comes through
is that progress does get made.
We do make inexorable
progress in obtaining a deeper
understanding of the
fundamental laws of physics,
and I think that's surely
one of the great intellectual
and cultural achievements
of all of humanity.
Thank you.
So this is actually--
there'll be another talk--
it's actually another
of the deep clues
to how to unify quantum
theory and gravity.